ça ce sont des voiles d'hivernage les
coûts pour réchauffer un peu la terre
pour préparer la culture comme ça
pendant pendant trois semaines ou un
mois ça réchauffe un peu la terre malgré
le froid à l'intérieur c'est quand même
plus chaud mais après ça va activer la
levée des semis dans quelques semaines
carottes et poireaux seront plantés dans
ces bacs de permaculture une technique
de jardinage bien particulière qui
permet d'économiser l'eau grâce à
différentes couches de terre c'est grâce
à l'humidité qui retiennent au fond de
la deûle à de la butte
on a mis des branches des composts
saradar l'humidité et en plus ça
décompose l'économie d'eau et de travail
aussi parce que comme ça on a moins à
désherber moins arrosées et ça pousse
beaucoup mieux présidente d'une
association de jardinage à guyancourt
hank de fo est une véritable passionnée
elle fait régulièrement découvrir son
jardin et donne ses conseils aux
visiteurs
malgré le froid hivernal elle se prépare
déjà au retour des beaux jours la terre
est très honnête et pas trop froid c'est
presque bon pour faire du sommet en
attendant la jardinière surveille ses
protégés qui ont passé l'hiver dans
leurs cabanes et celles à faire bella il
ya des foyers qui sont il faut les
tailler un travail régulier partagé
depuis quatre ans avec son association
de nombreux ateliers sont organisés pour
apprendre à avoir la main verte